president biden walking back his own
comments on federal payouts to migrant
families separated at the border
remember last week the president was
asked about reports that the department
of justice was considering paying up to
450 000
to those migrant families he called that
report quote garbage but even the aclu
pushed back and suggested that the
president may have been out of the loop
watch as president biden over the
weekend was forced to correct himself in
an exchange with our very own david
spunt
he said last week
that this report about migrant families
at the border getting payments uh was
garbage no i didn't say that let's get
it straight you said
everybody coming across the border gets
500 450 thousand dollars
for firing dude okay now here's the
thing
if in fact because of the the outrageous
behavior of the last administration
you coming across the border whether it
was legal or illegal and you lost your
child
you lost your child it's gone
you deserve some kind of compensation no
matter what the circumstance what that
will be i have no idea
i have no idea
yes doj
negotiating a settlement
and senior white house adviser cedric
richmond pushing back in the president's
defense
the president's in the loop but the
president said at the beginning of his
administration on the campaign trail
that he would have an independent
department of justice that he would not
direct the department of justice what to
do and
so that was all over the weekend
president biden says no i never called
that report garbage but we have the
receipts let's play biden from just
wednesday
if you guys keep sending that garbage
out yeah
but it's not true so this is a garbage
report yeah okay 450 450
000
per person is that what you're saying
that was separated from a family member
at the border under the last
administration that's not going to
happen
harris the president on wednesday
sounding very different than the
president on saturday that's because he
didn't remember what he said and he
didn't remember what peter said he
didn't remember what the question was
and he didn't remember what the answer
was or should be
i mean it's it's confusing
and we're doing this
days later imagine in the moment
when you now know that you have to clean
up on aisle seven and you can't even
remember what the reporter asked you so
what you'll do is you'll rephrase it
you'll do something that we're seeing
some democrats do you'll redefine a
moment it's not defund the police it's
reallocate funding
that was what the mayor of kansas city
told me when i interviewed him yeah it's
this it's that but but you have to have
an actual hold on what the facts were
before you can twist them and i'm not
convinced that he did i think you know
i think that maybe he got caught off
guard on that wait so every single
person peter corrects him know the ones
who were separated at the border under
the last administration then the next go
around he says and every single person
blah blah blah well again he's not
getting it right
it's adjudicating a situation that
happened at the border under the last
administration either he doesn't
understand
he's confused he's forgotten or he is
one heck of a tool by somebody who knows
exactly what they're doing to manipulate
him and i said it last week emily
that's not helpful whoever has the reins
on the guy who says they've instructed
me the president of the united states i
think it's time we need to know who they
are right because i don't know if they
have his best interest or ours at heart
it doesn't seem that way brian
interestingly okay so that wall street
journal report that was garbage turns
out it was actually reality we all knew
that to be the case i want to pull up a
quote from that initial wall street
journal piece
saying this one government lawyer
threatened to remove his name from the
case out of disagreement with the
potential settlement offer the source
said in another instance a department of
homeland security attorney involved in
the settlement talks complained on a
conference call that the payouts could
amount to more than some families of 9
11 victims received and another person
and senior department officials they
were in alignment on the amount and
disputed the 911 comparison uh did the
president just not know this was taking
place these discussions and threats to
resign over it you know i appreciate
that harris will chalk it up to not
remembering and that very well may be
the case but i just think he doesn't
care enough to want to get the details
straight i mean is this a president who
cares really about anything happening at
the border has he shown that he wants to
get the facts right that he wants to
understand cause and effect i haven't
seen him show that i've seen him show
indifferent so now we have a policy look
if you pay people half a million dollars
to cross the border illegally
they're going to cross the border more
often illegally that's obvious but if
that's not your concern if you don't
care about that then you're not going to
spend the time to get the facts straight
to explain it to the american people he
talks about straight talk if this isn't
the windiest talk we have ever gotten on
border policy i don't know
kennedy but getting to the heart of the
matter on this you know going back to
the last segment you know the secretary
of energy there going to the kamala
communications school with that laughing
tactic as was pointed out you know she
admitted over the weekend americans
could pay
could pay four dollars a gallon of gas
americans are going to face higher
heating costs likely so americans are
paying more but we'll pay the illegal
immigrants upwards of potentially a
quarter a half a million dollars all you
have to do is talk to some people who
are trying to immigrate into this
country legally and you know look at the
maze they have to go through which is so
complex and so poorly staffed and when
they have issues
and they're trying to do it the right
way they get deported they don't get
checks but you know i think we can
number one address the kids who have
been separated from their parents
sexually abused and trafficked under
this administration what are you going
to give them what are you going to give
their families and also
to all the moms who lost sons
to prison because of three strikes year
out laws and various other things that
follow from the 1994 crime bill are they
going to get compensation for losing
entire generations of men to the prison
system in this country to the failed war
on drugs that both the vice president
and the president had a very firm hand
in crafting especially the president and
he has tried to disavow himself from
some of the legislation that he authored
and pushed in the late 80s and 90s that
decimated families and communities and
ruined lives is he going to answer for
that great point and are the families
affected by drugs emily's american
citizens who have had opioids pour
across our southern border one d e agent
dea agent saying it's the worst it's
ever been are those families going to be
compensated not in the way that
apparently these families we just
mentioned earlier are yes he warned
essentially so first of all let's back
up for a second i think part of the
issue here is that the administration
thinks that americans have a goldfish
memory just like they do but we don't
and history belies exactly
and history belies exactly the kind of
duration that we need to have to look at
these kinds of things so for example the
dea just issued for the first time in
six years a public health safety alert
talking about the fact that there are
counterfeit pills being mass produced
with a deadly dose of fentanyl baked
inside two million almost two million
have been confiscated this year alone
that's more than two of the past years
combined there is enough deadly fentanyl
amount that can fit in the tip of a head
of a pencil and this is what is flowing
out on the streets this is why the state
that cares the most about our southern
border
protection is ohio it's not necessarily
because they see that the migrants are
directly depending depleting resources
in their small border towns it is
because they are feeling the deadly
effects of fentanyl of opioid abuse and
the like and so for this administration
to come in and pretend to kennedy's
point like they've had no hand in
crafting prior crime bills have had no
experience in the past 50 years of the
international narco cartel drug scene
and the impact on our american cities is
just absolutely disingenuous and that
dea agent also warned of an upcoming
cartel war that's going to happen in
juarez which we have also been seeing
again for the past decades that's why
our greatest ally remains the president
of mexico but that relationship has been
obliterated so it really goes so much
further than just the borders of our
states or cities or whatnot but the
bottom line is that americans are dying
and they're dying because that southern
border is open totally and i love how
indignant the president seemed over the
separation of families
when we've talked about you've said
like that over the people we lost in
afghanistan and what about you've said
in the guise of compassion this
administration's ushering in cruelty i'm
paraphrasing you there because these
illegal immigrant girls and these
facilities who are having to use the
restroom and bags that's humanitarian
you know give me a break i don't believe
biden cares do you no i don't and i
think it's the question remains does he
have the acuity to care but either way
talking doesn't matter because what we
care about is actions and his actions
message that he does not care yeah well
he said was so important though kennedy
taking it back and and looking using the
pass to look forward i say let's pick a
wednesday because wednesdays we were
pink let's go down to the white house
you're in pink ready to go
and let's ask your questions to the
president of the united states i would
love to watch that hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
gonna miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now